quand j'ai suivi emmanuel macron à
cette année c'est que le délai entre le
remaniements il ya toujours des
viens vraiment bien ensemble je vous
hidalgo avait dit non déjà le prétexte
pourrait rester qui pourrait passer à
devenu et rennes etc c'est la leçon
une tête mais exact et ont repris hier
déliter la confiance vous de nous
poids lourds de personnes qui ont fait
cet écosystème que je ne décris en parle
matignon bernard cazeneuve a déjà été
peut-être darmanin tous de droite
mandat il a besoin de techniciens
co-organise voilà et la semaine d'après
investi
composition
est qui et l'émancipation si pour
figeac dans le lot vendredi dernier jean
les informations mais on essaye de
envisagé pour remplacer éventuellement
aileron c'est un requin et le requin
désindustrialisation qui résiste au vote
dans les papiers de ce matin tu as fait
manuel valls d'ailleurs peut-être je
l'intérieur il faudrait que le service
chef des armées et président de la
équilibres à respecter des écailles ou
leurs preuves dans la campagne c'est
ministre en charge de la planification
et il ya cette poussée du rassemblement
réception on s'en souvient alors dites
matin en retard et puis il repart il se
recomposition politique avant les
développer tous ah bon arthur c'est qui
sens un passeur de me donner de noms je
deuxième tour des élections
lens avec les élections législatives à
ministre en fin de quinquennat hollande
crois qu'il dit ou emmanuel enfin c'est
alexis kohler le secrétaire général de
qu'est ce qu'il fait il mort il mord
dès que le gouvernement ait effet il
être à une chaise un peu plus loin le
c'est petit meeting
place taksim exactement pour son dernier
quelqu'un qui face à corneilhan qu'ils
résumer très très vite évidemment tout
présidentielles et les législatives et
invoqué à l'époque c'était que le comité
gérald darmanin et sébastien lecornu
remarquez au passage et c'est vrai alors
infographie nous aident
on parle de politique et maintenant et
lis quand même ce que nous disent en
territoriaux représenter les régions les
front devenu rassemblement national qui
met en retrait lorsqu'emmanuel macron
informer que moi mes skis emmanuel
république ça c'est l'événement
écologique avec deux ministres pour
législatives vous avez un programme
l'un des deux ou les deux peut-être
national qui est pas qu elle pas un très
venir qui vont qui vont pas forcément
pourquoi pour son propre calendrier et
meeting jean castex étaient présents et
presque grand débat comme il avait tant
fassent tourner la goutte ans quand en
moi justement guy dupont moretti qui va
le premier ministre ah ça c'est il
leurs noms sont souvent cités comme ceux
bois nathan qui veut dire on aura
international olympique devrait venir
d'ailleurs je crois que c'est les deux à
l'elysée s'y serait dommage et emmanuel
les gens s'étaient brillamment écoute et
complet on remercie aussi raphaël l'as
de six semaines au lieu de quatre
maintenant que va-t-il faire emmanuel
sébastien lecornu il a d'ailleurs
ça s'accompagne de mesures qui ont été
incontournable
macron on veut à edouard philippe parce
gros ce que vous me dites c'est que
faisait des points presse avec les
qui c'est arrivé ils chercher tout le
sûrement une personnalité du ps comme
à la différence des autres cérémonies
bon signe parce que ça indique un pays
provinces les territoires il ya la
l'appuyer qui seront un ministre en
permet ces espèces de droite sociale de
son propre avenir sans doute qui est
justement est en avance il est 14 heures
faudrait une boule de cristal vous
ya bruno le maire pour le maire c'est
l'incarnation c'est lui et on a besoin
marquer maintenant les six semaines à
qui pourraient intégrer un gouvernement
semaines ce qui allonge le temps pour
faire des repérages le lendemain de la
dragons régis excellente journée a très
macron il a été élu dimanche pour un
fait rire la sortie des défilés je
macron voilà la deuxième partie de son
présentés sur le
en direct en général macron surprend
tellement fait ses preuves dans la
journalistes
vous lâchez tout vous concentrez arthur
temps emmanuel macron quitté fuyant sur
qu'on a l'impression que toutes les
partir on est sûr qu'ils vont partir
comme premier ministre peut-être qu'on
l'avez pas installé sur le normal je
divisé l'absence de fait louis les ce
parité en fin dé tout un tas déquilibre
d'investiture qu'on a vu ces dix
edouard philippe jamet à côté à tel
charge de la planification territoriale
dans le son horizon sans vouloir faire
bernard cazeneuve par exemple aimé il
campagne qu'aujourd'hui il commence à
réussis un petit peu et c'est un petit
second mandat il entre dans des semaines
popularité de jean castex auprès des
soirée électorale d'accord et donc la
l'allongement de l'âge de départ à la
venir bondues secousse est cette
les déplacements parce que lui prenait
crises qu'a traversées emmanuel macron
cerveau
une personnalité qui est extrêmement
vite merci
dans ses choix du premier ministre
38 on est en direct on analyse cet
suivra ça n'attend alors une question
d'un premier ministre un peu plus
gaullisme social un petit peu et donc ça
peu c'est même plus mauvaise que ça
faire des boulettes fait d'accord voilà
et un ministre en charge de la
n'aime pas ça soyez madame irma jat
dans les membres du gouvernement ils ne
vous donne les premières informations où
être attaquée sur le vote et la reine
comme
jeunes qui le résume certes avec un
un mauvais jeu de mot avec le nom de son
qui sont extrêmement complexes à trouver
intéressante parce qu'il a passé cinq
point qu'un moment emmanuel macron
technique qui lui soit les mains dans le
voyons si nous avons une surprise pour
campagne avait fini maintenant arthur
mairie de paris s'inquiéter soi disant
dernières années même avant d'ailleurs
son temps pour être en retard pour
s'entendait très mal avec emmanuel
seront pas reconduits est-ce qu'on a des
retraite de gauche et de droite c'est
décisives pour lancer au mieux son
c'est un petit peu comme si vous voulez
quand même emmanuel macron que veut-il
je pense au gilet jaune et à la réforme
répond sur une passerelle puisqu'on a
cambouis voilà donc toute la machinerie
s'est incarnée par gérald darmanin ça a
parti 2027 il va viser en plus il faudra
ans à bercy ce qui n'était pas arrivé
planification énergétique c'était la
saluer pour serrer des mains puisqu'ils
et qui en général serve au président à
vont aller les ministres importants qui
on comprend donc plus le temps est long
noms là on peut dire j'ai entendu
apprêt présidentielle est ce que va
macron pendant très longtemps sa date d
quel est l'agenda des manuels macron
une association étudiante qui se
on peut le dire que les pelouse soit
arnaud tu attends
il y aura pas de remontée du tapis rouge
toute la machinerie de l'état ce que
j'ai jamais le
donner des noms ce que vous allez me
petit côté un peu rigolo au premier
l'émancipation par la liberté donc c'est
et plus vous avez de risques de faire
assisté à la comment dirais-je la
considèrent emmanuel maintenant que
des retraites c'est impulsée par edouard
deuxième quinquennat on va poser plein
plu à emmanuel macron durant la campagne
roselyne bachelot par exemple y en a
resteront ou donc on repart de bruno le
le loup la premier ministre on a en tout
défaites alors on a vu des photos avec
mettrait dans le dans la cour de l'école
grande annonce des manuels macro à
dans les outre-mers ce qui se passe dans
faire de son gouvernement le renouveler
pouvoir faire manuel macron avec son
lequel je vous renvoie donc vous me
dans les jours à venir presque demain
avoir des relais territoriaux en vue des
and la fin des années hollande et de
dégradée jonchaient de canettes de bière
chaque minute de retard c'est un point
par définition il y aura pas d'entretien
que emmanuel macron compose dans les
donner ce qu'ils ont déjà perdu on dit
marsala vient d'assurer en étant direct
matignon s'est quand même machine à
d'autres et marlène schiappa dont le nom
un objectif de gauche c'est un objectif
et essaierait de faire venir les faire
voilà c'était jamais arrivé donc bruno
manière dont on charge les porte
et donc oui gérald darmanin a marqué des
ministre ducobu de celui qui disait à
de questions mais c'est de répondre à
je sais pas 50% 75% il ya pas un
nos ministes des outre-mer voilà ce qui
une connerie et c'est surtout ça qui qui
dites oui mais allez ça va bien se dire
gouvernement notamment via un jeu de
après demain que va-t-il faire où
maire pour que ce soit clair pour les
d'empathie gagné d'accord et donc il
des enfants il ya eu certaines photos
philippe lhez gilet jaune de 80 km/heure
l'ensemble du quinquennat bernard
une tout particulièrement qui nous
cas son profil est bon alors macron
conteneurs au port du havre manuel
entre le sortant et le nouveau puisque
élections là et même accro arrive dans
que les noms qui sortent comme cd alain
de gauche par des outils de droite c'est
avec double nature et donc elisabeth
arbitrer si c'est des décisions du matin
compter de 15 jours on se souvient de
internautes simoneau le maire de quitter
et j'en passe et donc la mairie de paris
veut dire que sébastien lecornu
qu alexis colère lire et où lui alexis
va-t-il aller vous avez tout à fait
points et fera partie d'une manière ou
adhérer les gens à l'association quoi
problème de personnel emmanuel macron a
inquiète dans l'âme acronis et de tenir
intéresse qui sera le nouveau premier
revient souvent donné comme étant dans
le maire c'est quelqu'un qui s'est
surveiller ce site est très bien non une
chaises musicales au sein des ministres
cazeneuve aujourd'hui il n'est
c'est le même et donc il descendra de
qui ont filtré notamment par les équipes
bercy ça veut dire qu'il ya une place
était un jour il était toujours en
macron donc est monté pour assister à
flaques futur les futurs dont deux
raison d'abord demain il ya un premier
claques sans mal alors souvient tous de
donc c'est emmanuel macron qui
un monde à ne pouvoir pas se représenter
au soir à prendre elle a la haute main
vraisemblablement est dans une position
km et cette fameuse réforme des
bornes elle a été ministre des
qui essayent peut-être de tirer les
le en même temps des macros convivial
d'une autre de l'avenir d'emmanuel macro
vide à bercy d'accord si la place vide à
avait déjà freiné emmanuel macron les
les dents les partantes jean-michel
qui je cois dites moi j'imagine que vous
ministre françois-xavier bourmaud
manifestement plus tôt franck ça avec
colère parce qu'il te fasse abandonné en
construit une assise politique
retard et donc il était toujours 15
cessé il ya deux vous soulevez dans
son appartement il ira directement dans
les troupes sans qu'il y ait une phrase
femme voilà ça c'est la priorité et
une charge décharge edouard philippe
donc il est défait de toutes ces
circonscriptions avec le parti des
s'installe au milieu d'une place ou bien
ces formules avec son accent des
de brigitte macron voit la salle des
l'économie fonctionne bien le chômage
bonjour arthur bernard bonjour dont
transports qui a fait la réforme de la
mètres derrière le cortège est donc on
ficelles en douce et ils ont déjà perdu
pleine nature alexis colère monde entend
sur sur l'administration donc c'est
d'obtenir un poste à poste important et
bercy est rempli par alexis colère par
difficilement mais je vois où vous
allez on arrête avec les noms je vais
blogueur dupond moretti et répétait
la dans la salle des fêtes pour une
conseil des ministres alors la règle
contraintes c'est à dire qui peut faire
emmanuel macron nous est d'accord on
retraites qui n'a pas été fait pour
relations entre se sont encore dégradées
avez des infos bruno le maire ont dit
votre question vous soulevez deux points
baisse c'est lui qui était la
d'edouard philippe j'en viens au
fêtes à 20 heures en fait l annonce des
donc été avec louise à 60 mètres de
sûr ces équipes font le travail pour
de travers un mot de travers qui fasse
un gouvernement totalement à sa main
journaliste au service politique du
bercy d'accord mais bercy ça suppose de
sncf elle a été ministre de l'écologie
vous en citer un dernier puis après on
sait comment ça finit cette histoire
toujours le même gouverner avec le
au stade emmanuel macron c'est ça ou pas
voulez en venir voilà c'est un projet en
l'instant l'âge pivot et l'âge pivot s
législatif justement est ce qu'il ya des
sera le dernier c'est plus du 0% mathieu
très intéressants le premier c'est la
maniema qu'on souhaite que ce soit une
que ça commence à défourailler pour pour
cérémonie qu'il qu'il annonce comme
résultats il y avait à les quelques 200
responsabilité de ce dossier c'est un
moretti il ya le drian dix ans de suite
dans cette campagne surtout le jeu cette
plutôt a plutôt un technicien mais avait
qu'il veut aller peut-être ce affaires
exemple secrétaire général de l'elysée
jean castex est très populaire emmanuel
perdre des députés et qui au fil des six
pour finir par la législative parce que
c'est que c'est surtout il ya les mâcon
c'est un grand classique de la politique
hauteur pour observer cette commande est
gouvernement qu'on appelle gouvernement
fait le ski même macron explique assez
hors peut-être sur les questions de
alors qu'on cherche aujourd'hui
faire en sorte qu'ils aient du monde qui
phrase voilà que j'y arrive je vois vous
quoi ça il peut l'avoir en travers de la
remettre bruno le maire ailleurs mais
question du banc de touche de la macro
figaro arthur berlan votre jugement je
étant plutôt sobre sans trop de monde
personnage politique qui a du poids donc
lui faire la peau bon on a on a fait le
je vous dis pas que c'est plus probable
de faire circuler les noms pour les
inquiétudes j'ai vu les premiers
castex donc non mais par le premier
quelqu'un chargé de l'écologie est elle
étrangères qu'il veut pourquoi pas viser
et il ne l'a pas fait blank je sais pas
personnes peut-être un peu moins invité
clinker maire de nancy voilà il ya toute
macron le sait jean castex n'a pas
au gouvernement jean yves le drian
qui connaît l'histoire puisqu'il a déjà
parité ou ce serait sa seule contrainte
est si possible le monde soit plutôt
l'avez sur l'île si cette place dans un
ni en effet pour les amateurs de sport
semaines et main amène la halle à
un jouet les scénarios qui circulent
je lis ce matin dans votre excellent
grosse ce procédé et puis emmanuel
sondages y est retombé plutôt rassurant
bruno le maire nous expliquent qu'ils
tôt dans son quinquennat quand il est
vraisemblablement bon après ça fait ça
fait le coup voilà tu vois de voir
montre votre bouquin sur emmanuel macron
gorge et manu dire il ya une forme de
favorable lorsqu'on l'a vu à figeac il y
avec un paramètre ajouté si je puis me
d'ambition pour l'avenir ce qui est
dévitalisées tiens une fois que les noms
cette jeune génération maire de nogent
foyer de l'entourage des veinules macron
thé gérald darmanin bardon jeux
ministre jean castex et les ministres de
on connaît tous le banc de touche une
à l'elysée pour suivre les résultats
d'accord si cette classe vidées rang
est aujourd'hui ministre du travail où
si c'est une priorité c'est en tout cas
élu en 2017 c'est qu'il lui faut dix ans
visent ni matignon ni l'éducation alors
éducation nationale on a plein de
philippe lui faire ça ils sont là ils
papier à tous les deux arthur et
mais sur le sur les impératifs de relais
quand même pour emmanuel macron non
l'éventuelle majorité des macros en
emmanuel macron va pouvoir difficilement
rigidité chez edouard philippe qui qui
c'est vous dire si vous le connaissez
équipe elle peut être dans le sport
avec emmanuel macron soirée très sobre a
macron se met à répondre aux
une volonté exprimée peut-être une
alexis colère passerait du secrétariat
traditionnels darmanin lui il lui aussi
aussi un bon point pour emmanuel macron
les noms circulent monfils et se
maire ps exactement cette jeune
son gouvernement actuel d'accord ça
permettre c'est qu'il va les vaincrons
alors il ya il ya une inquiétude c'est
rumeurs comme ça amélie monchal
journalistes ils répondent assez
avait des gens extrêmement un gilet
il parle beaucoup d'efficacité ne sautez
fait partie du jeu ce que les achats le
là c'est ça qu'est ce qui se fait à son
pour réformer la pour réformer la france
elle a eu notamment à gérer le plan un
sont le françois-xavier dernière
françois-xavier
longuement une dizaine de minutes une
performante si elle a un bon banc de
montchalin cela dit moi alors déjà pour
c'est un lieu comme tous les mercredis
volonté de façade mais en tout cas oui
emmanuel macron réélu c'est qu'il
s'en passer bruno le maire décrit un
génération de grand-mère ps on à mathieu
général de l'élysée à bercy par exemple
jaune qu'il usait et aspect êtes un
et donc lorsqu'on lui demande à jean
fatiguer s'éviter le président a plutôt
locaux ça il est totalement dégagé de
bureau mais où on voit ce gros collier
priori emmanuel macron qui découvrant
l'agacé même macron qui aiment plutôt
dessous de la ligne de flottaison c'est
un problème avec edouard philippe ya un
pas les étapes on va venir à tous ses
dira pas partie mais cette phrase c'est
figaro.fr ne connaissent sans doute pas
douzaine de minutes et puis lorsqu'il se
il a fait ses preuves durant la campagne
question il j'ai entendu que emmanuel
touche et qu'elle a à l'heure de jeu on
et qu'il ne s'interdit d'utiliser aucun
françois-xavier bourmaud prémonitoire
celle de la boulette en 2007 après
de 10 h il y aura un con c'est un compte
à dire les 281 la majorité
vous avez raison de dire deuxième point
jeune une solution au sortir de la crise
gilet jaune qu'ils aient un bras
commencer toute la subtilité de ce genre
être qui est plutôt quelqu'un qui aime
castex soit en tout cas lorsque les
ministres pour savoir s'il reste il
remaniement son nom ressort pour
ce qui s'appelle 1 75% de pouvoir de
les résultats lâche cette phrase devant
fait rentrer la fraîcheur emmanuel
klein à nancy johanna rolland à nantes
est ce qu'on nous a expliqué avec
effectue actuellement en tout cas dès
place libre à l'elysée place libre à
retourne
ses de ces contraintes donc on peut
problème avec edouard philippe il ya un
dans les nourrissons sont inconnus et
rendu à la fin avec gabriel exactement
tendance à aller chercher effet l'effet
c'est ce geste assez important assez
outil que ces outils soient de droite ou
macron le pen le tango des fossoyeurs
du coc vide où elle a eu à gérer aussi
pas des doors fille avait un qui était
parle au delà de la politique
d'honneur il a été rapidement exfiltré à
à éclaircir si vous avez de gauche ou de
matignon lui à chaque fois fait savoir
françois-xavier c'est que ce qui avait
d'exercice c'est qu'en général on fait
questions lui sont posées en interne de
peut-être imaginer ce la mise en place
macron à une époque envisageait de
l'élection de nicolas sarkozy à 53% il
gros a alors ouvrant
tout le monde le plus dur commence et
qu'il sera investi son dernier mandat
macron a toujours eu un petit souci là
l'elysée julien de normandie ministre de
cette réforme de l'assurance chômage
c'est d'ailleurs l'une des raisons pour
être dans l'agilité si un sens sans
politicienne et des noms convient de
benoît paillaugue à marseille dont le
benjamin du gouvernement fera le ce
on est en direct 14h54 ont fini cela il
de gauche mais dans son
plu au président c'est son côté maire de
pour vous dire comme ils connaissent le
qu'il ne veut pas matignon qui veut
figeac dans la même fenêtre une dame
de surprise bon c'est pas toujours vrai
dissoudre l'assemblée nationale avant
nuisance balle à 1075 le score c'est de
manière un peu détournée brand quand tu
dessus c'est qu'en effet c'est un petit
lesquelles il pourrait être amené à
savoir qu on veut quelque chose pour
descendu qui était déjà en bas et qui
puis emmanuel macron sort en jeu n'a pas
droite ça c'est la ventilation des deux
symbolique il ya la proclamation d'abord
oui c'est la constitution interdit
dans qu'elisabeth bornes elle a plutôt
l'agriculture qui pourraient d'accord
tourcoing en fait mr d'une paire d
contrainte et leur relation s'est
donner
jacques djian on a vu manuel dans tout
horizon sont l'idéal vers lequel il il
partir sur ses 42 membres il y en a
peu le jeu du taquin vous savez on doit
avoir autre chose il vaut mieux jouer
les législatives c'est oublier ça oui ça
devrais arrêter matignon qu'est-ce qui
mais là les noms qui circulent vous avez
qu'on appelle le débrief du conseil des
me semble que c'est jean louis borloo
il ya une politique à mener politiques
dossier vous avez signé un excellent
explosé de joie à quoi sert exactement
attendait il s'était fait la malle
ce corps d'anne hidalgo au premier tour
va encore quelques minutes j'ai
c'est vraiment oser dire ça est-ce qu'on
alors si vous me dites que c'est
marqué des points il n'empêche que c'est
déplacer des carrés pour former une
réglages tu sais pas de tva sociale les
écoles qui s'affrontent au tandem alors
pourrait intéresser il y a deux
secrétaire général de l'elysée ensuite
cela c'est tout cette affiche a été
de demain par le conseil constitutionnel
depuis la façon d'un dernier mandat il
il a explosé de joie au champ de mars
beaucoup dont les français ont pas ou
ministres comme ça c'est le rendez vous
justement ça m'amène à cette question
injuste enfin l'ancien maire puisqu'il
distendu avec de la confiance et du
pôles
de la présidentielle bon vous pouvoir
filiale anglaise à la edouard philippe
donc du côté il faut donner des gages à
lutte est un art dont bruno le maire lui
papier ce matin dans le figaro c'était
ça c'est oublier mais la question de la
dans le bain dans les arcanes mais on le
d'un cran une première qui considère
fait pas un peu des pronostics un peu
image mais il ya toujours une case vide
qui est calé pour demain et qu'il ne
demain mercredi proclamation des
intéressant et que c'est un gros
ministères deux marocains pour lesquels
tance l émancipation
est en ministre il ne peut plus être
et on imagine aller piocher s'il faut
une ancienne préfète et donc le risque
de gauche de droite qu'elle va être
réagir poser toutes vos questions vous
peu entendu parler et puis va avoir
pourrait se représenter son dernier
projections en sièges pour l'ump à
il y à aussi gabriel attal porte parole
respect c'est ce qu'ils disent des deux
quelle politique va mener emmanuel
non plus d'ailleurs c'était il y avait
ça toujours c'est ça toujours été ça
dissolution elle est intéressante parce
retiré par le service d'ordre qui a une
farfelu permettez moi de vous dire ces
pourrait avoir des ambitions
donc ça c'est pendant la campagne dont
qu'il faut encore travailler la droite
en une du journal vous ouvrez et vous
dans le fauteuil du maire il est donc
résultats officiels pourtant c'est
fait dire à qui au journaliste rannou
avez compris les deux messieurs qui sont
personnelle des français arthur une
cette politique c'est compliqué avant le
besoin de faire de la politique et pour
que emmanuel macron réélu donc on l'a
bougera pas ensuite donc juste à vous
la droite
présidentielles
l'ancien premier ministre agace d'autant
emmanuel macron gérard collomb est parti
bus circulaient alors ce ne sont que les
du gouvernement oui qui a convaincu qui
il n'a en tout cas pas fermé la porte
macron dans les toutes prochaines
volonté de contrôler l'image mais il ya
mandat consécutif exact que la
côtés mais quand on s'en tient aux actes
assez peu d'ambiance contrairement au
il n'a pas marqué de points voilà vous
dans la société civile peut être encore
donc on aurait catherine vautrin
important et puis ensuite une fois que
d'être non pas technique comme skis
un jour ou l'autre donc c'est il en a eu
l'époque font état je sais plus mais
premier tour on disait emmanuel macron à
conseiller municipal de tourcoing mais
qu'il faut finir de fracturer la droite
semaines on imagine qu'il ne se lancera
qui sont l'éducation nationale et la
d'accord donc nous appelle alors ça
il a fallu quinze jours pour le
réseaux sociaux mais le nom d'arnaud
dit pourra pas se représenter à l'issue
ça il a besoin de poids lourds
à côté de moi savent tout de emmanuel
a fait ses preuves qui a convaincu
constitution depuis la réforme de 2008
aussi cette volonté donc d'être au
avez ce ce papier je vous montre le camp
louvre en 2017 il y avait à l'époque
plus qu'il n'a pas été jugé très
me dites alors après sur le fond je lis
cette proclamation a eu lieu il ya cette
d'ailleurs il est égal à la primaire l
ça c'est une de ses chaussures 10,7 ça a
on voit que pendant la campagne encore
montebourg où on peut sortir de
politiques parce que le quinquennat
et donc de nommer quelqu'un de droite et
nathalie kosciusko morizet bons sont des
question à propos de jean castex vous en
qu'ils aient jugé talentueux qui a
emmanuel macron cherchera peut-être mais
milieu des gens et de faire des mini
l'effet une campagne plutôt à droite on
pas immédiatement avant les législatives
c'est lui qui a été lu la dernière d'une
remplacer à beauvau ça a été dur
enfin en gros entre la boulaye entre le
de nicolas sarkozy interdit de faire
de son deuxième mandat ce qui veut dire
40000 personnes là il en annonce 3000 il
macron restons un moment sur la soirée
c'est un tass les gens futur centre
performant durant la campagne ça c'est
justice deux grands chantiers sur
cérémonie d'investiture qui a priori
s'annonce tellement tellement agité qui
un dans les couloirs du palais lisez
un peu trop techno et donc ça risque
parlait ce matin dans l'article en casse
puis une autre qui considèrent que le
sur la réforme des retraites qu'est ce
meeting stand-up un peu improvisé
quoi je veux qu'on ne leur dit pas je
philippe qui a assuré l'intérim et
parle de la retraite notamment et puis
plus de deux mandats présidentiels
entre celles edouard philippe qui
longtemps rêvé de l'écologie et qui
donné tous les secrets on vous appelle
air de 2016 pour la présidence de
du candidat au président les secrets de
n'importe quel nom du chapeau j'ai
l'élection de sarkozy et la boulette de
que l'enjeu pour lui ça va être de
été aussi l'un des échecs de ce qu'il
série thor il son côté son côté son côté
consécutifs est donc emmanuel macron
dimanche quand même comment ça s'est
pour toi alors exactement ce qui s'est
devrait avoir lieu autour du 12 mai
finalement cet été christophe castaner
souhaite une bonne ambiance c'est que
noms qui circulent en catherine vautrin
lesquels emmanuel macron a promis de
taxi il a plutôt séduit les français là
alors sa défaveur c'est une question de
peut pas partir la fleur au fusil comme
l'impression que ça a été des motifs on
c'était notre aile droite c'est devenu
qu'il peut faire qu'est-ce qu'il peut
y en avait sans doute moins appuyé
entre deux tours il fallait chercher les
travail à droite est terminée qu'il y
parfois sans note donc pas toujours
macron deux voiliers moi je les
semblerait s'intéresser lui aussi à
explique qui fait peur qui explique que
conserver le pouvoir parce que la guerre
on vous gonds du monde des jeunes on
passé pour emmanuel macron j'ai pas
borloo estime en gros que le sarkozy a
mais quand gilles legendre n'a plus fait
engager pour montrer qu'il est quand
financiers du tout à l'heure c'est
faire beaucoup la justice ça a été les
puisque la fin de mandat constitutionnel
en 2017 avec une équipe de débutants ou
voix de la gauche il a parlé beaucoup
vendredi qu'ils avaient presque manière
mer d'abord qui apporte emmanuel macron
passé c'est que vous savez que lorsqu'un
tous ceux qui sont retrouvés autour de
l'éducation nationale il faut se
un aileron ça veut dire quoi ce qui n'a
lit majeur en est revenu ça c'est à des
aura des ralliés l air et que tout ça
de succession va démarrer et le pouvoir
personnalité je vous relance
réussis tu avais alors c'est lui qui va
les gens savent pas forcément qui sait
vous dit ah il est possible que c'est un
manuel macro on voulait éviter de
marine le pen peut gagner qui explique
même actif sans justement faire de
d'écologie est ce qu'on sait il faut
plutôt une bonne cote de popularité est
choses qui m'intéressent on va essayer
la faire à la présidence du groupe l om
quand il va choisir son premier ministre
souvenir que gabriella talent sa
la table du conseil des ministres demain
président de la république se déplace
françois-xavier au président est dans
faire campagne grâce au calme alors
c'est le 13 mai donc c'est avant le 13
presque là il va avoir besoin de
pas joué le rôle de kiki était attendu
accueilli avec un éclat de rire du côté
ce cette carte territoire oui cette
n'a plus beaucoup d'importance et qu'il
états généraux de la justice qui se sont
plaisir une grande fête un grand soir de
un mécanisme ans se déplaçait à
d'en débattre ensemble vous pouvez
un peu taquiné des journalistes que le
comme les gens ne savaient pas qui est
promouvoir un candidat comme ça
première entrée au gouvernement avant
perdu 50 députés la boule a oui c'est
que si jamais elle était élue lui même
sont absolument pas assuré de se
il a fallu renvoyer christophe castaner
il va aussi faire en sorte qu'on ne
quand même quelqu'un une personne qui
bêtises ce qu'il peut apprendre par
échecs du quinquennat d'abord à
écosystème way où les noms circulent
edouard philippe et comme il ne savait
achevées en même temps que la fin de son
de l'elysée d'accord mais je crois que
quelque part il ya d'abord toujours un
son cv est lui aussi était ancienne
indirectement c'est ce qu'on a appelé
militant exactement donc moins
faut donc donner des gages à la gauche
ce qu'il pourrait rester au gouvernement
d'en être le porte parole c'était
mai pour sûr peut-être autour du 10 12
l'assemblée nationale où le groupe
incarne les idées qui veut mettre en
sera candidat en 2027 enfin il ya tout
exemple son costume de commandeur et
attention pour bruno le maire c'est
de lui pendant le pendant la campagne et
là bas etc etc donc premier problème en
retrouver évidemment ce papier sur
victoire il était attendu un peu le
retrouver la semaine prochaine où là où
reproduisent pas les valls hollande les
personnes qui un peu à la façon de cette
carte t zone des 1 marquée par la
pas qui était jean castex et presse la
l'assemblée nationale il ya eu société
quinquennat et pour lesquels il veut
accueil républicain quelle que soit
une campagne subliminal avec
d'ambiance un disco au moins fort avec
on a déjà vu ça des premiers ministres
pas rien là c'est pas rien et zakaria
majoritaire sera celui qui fera la pluie
pour tirer les enseignements du second
directrice de cabinet de ségolène royal
secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre de
très vite dans des discussions au
même dans les 5 min si l'on voulait dire
dans deux semaines lors des prochains
mai et donc il y à cette cérémonie où
président autour de lui c'était très
place assez flou alors oui il me semble
ça remonte à ça remonte à beaucoup plus
météo pour l ancien ministre de jacques
françois-xavier c'est à dire que lui va
l'étiquette du maire et donc lorsque
civile qu est ce qui est arrivé gros
créer 8500 magistrats et personnels
un tas de choses comme ça de petits
repartir sur l'international guerre en
compliqué c'est tout l'enjeu est là et
lefigaro.fr on va passer au très sérieux
moins de souffle que 2017 et puis
espèce de quad fort qui a dominé le
téléphone ou dans des rencontres où là
parce que ça peut vous pas faire passer
tout à fait à quoi aurait donc çà çà çà
effet le banc de touche en main cronje
relégués à une certaine manière mais
comptes l'on voit et on en parle
on dément cette fausse rumeur n'est pas
sarkozy fillon c'est à dire vous savez
se déplacer partout mettre son visage
chirac président du grand reims voilà
petits marqueur qui ont été placés et
l'éducation nationale chargée du et ses
puis c'est quelqu'un qui est déjà dans
laurent fabius président du conseil
tour donc ça c'est quelque chose qui est
nouvellement quasiment la moitié du
sous la ligne de flottaison et
tendu parce qu'il avait les chiffres de
et le beau temps donc emmanuel macron
judiciaires et l'école c'est l'un des
mais t'es peut-être pas d'accord il me
c'est un président candidat c'est
rester dans leur environnement problème
et donc il faudra voir comment il
montre là vous me dites payage à gauche
emmanuelle et brigitte macron qui tout
loin que que cette campagne en fait si
quinquennat au sein du gouvernement
partout et puis vous imaginez bien que
ukraine a lorsqu'il à la question lui a
messieurs mais une petite question quand
le moment où à l'elysée et à matignon on
groupe issu de la société civile
compliquer les choses entrent à me dire
nus donc il a fait ses premières armes
constitutionnel prononce un discours
sensiblement la même chose c'est-à-dire
nouvelle mais bien sûr mais je sais pas
réussit à élargir à dépasser encore
qui n'est pas maire d'arras nathalie
quand il fait planer dans l'air cette ce
c'est important mais ce qu'elle est
qui ont profondément profondément agacé
puisse dès la fin du conseil des
on rentre dans la passe dans la phase de
de suite après reprennent leur voiture
on refait l'histoire la brouille entre
que là dans le mois et demi qui vient
les affiches qui seront placardées
président et du gouvernement on l'a vu
semble que ça à l'heure et qu'en réalité
chantiers aussi principaux de son
même anne hidalgo a voulu embêter
le paysage bon ballon pour reprendre sur
pour introniser investir le président
qu emmanuel macron s'est rendu par
été posée à plusieurs reprises qu'il a
bruno le maire edouard philippe il y
qui n'a pas réussi à imprimer il faut
au sacre à au ministère de l'éducation
très forte poussée de marine le pen
se tire un peu dans les pattes pour
remaniement donc dès qu'on va croiser un
et d'autres d'autant plus qu'arnaud
devant les écoles et les bureaux de vote
le programmes des manuels macron on le
ministres s'ouvre cette séquence
oui mais après des petites parenthèses
davantage que ce qu'il a fait et puis
kosciusko morizet ancien ministre de
peint pardon à un petit peu terne
nouveau quinquennat sur lequel il veut
en train d'évoluer dans la tête de
emmanuel macron le soir du premier tour
toujours dit sur le fait de se rendre en
avant les législatives
petit bruit de dissolution il explique
emmanuel macron et edouard philippe elle
direction la résidence de la lanterne à
exemple à denain au lendemain du premier
espérer ramasser la mise derrière wave
et donc je reviens en deux mots pardon
bruno le maire lui l'heure ce moment
il pourrait avoir envie d'y revenir à
avait le corps nu aussi gérald darmanin
remaniement d'accord ce qu emmanuel
ce sera le député de la circonscription
on ne fait rien on reste discret sur
montebourg dans les cinq minutes qui
ministre alors qu'est ce qui se passe
macron voix juste une anecdote dernière
c'est à dire comme on l'a vu avec alain
connaît depuis 2010 est c'est le même il
deuxième sujet dans votre question qui
sur cette question que cette citation
alors qu'il ya cinq ans il était arrivé
nicolas sarkozy
tour dans le pas de calais à denain la
dire que c'est compliqué en arriver
isabelle borne ça fait cinq ans qu'ils
ukraine et ou en russie c'est qu'il ne
démarre au déconfinement le premier
en cela on est on est on est encore
chaque fois qu'on le voit parle beaucoup
défaut de l'écologie si gabriel attal
versailles où ils ont passé la nuit où
macron s'est fixé deux bornes temporel
écrit en petit et en très gros on a bien
retiré de la vie politique vous la fait
suivaient le l'apparition de son nom
aussi aux députés attention n'oubliez
juppé qui après avoir été à matignon a
qu'est ce qu'on dit il paraît que non
c'est à dire ceux qui ont émergé dans
que vous citiez juste et c'était notre
en tête au second est arrivé largement
tout et célia cible il ya déjà eu une
n'a pas changé l'élection présidentielle
futur avec davantage de liberté pour les
élection présidentielle en 2017 on avait
aient le gouvernement je suis je ne suis
puisque emmanuel macron voulait que la
maire ps ancien député frondeuse a
peut-être un peu loin par dont arthur
emmanuel macron prend la parole à son
était si elle me revient le
pas qu'à tout moment patron je peux
ils ont passé la journée de lundi et
d'éducation de l'étonnant
largement en tête mais où il ya toujours
les médias étaient déjà des
déconfinement où il ya une opposition
dans la valise pour matignon après un
s'y rendrait pas pour faire de
quitte le porte parolat ça veut dire que
réintégré le gouvernement de françois
revenir retiré de la vie politique et
est une élection de mi-mandat de
la première celle qu'il espère tenir
compris que cette campagne des
aile droite c'est devenu un aileron donc
mais il ya eu il ya eu deux premiers
j'entends plutôt qui sonne ça tourne
fait un concours de pronostics
personnalités politiques plus ou moins
boulette il y en a déjà eu alors bruno
tour eiffel scintille derrière lui
très forte entre les mêmes macron qui
dont ils sont revenus à paris lundi soir
le porte parolat évident et donc il
mettre tout le monde dehors voilà
l'affichage que s'il s'y rend c'est
législatives elles seraient nationale
renouvellement combien combien sont quoi
puis petit handicap à la tête d'un
celle du 4 mai prochain conseil des
confirmation une sorte de mid-term en
accueilli emmanuel macron au nom de
connaissent très bien alors que pour le
enseignants à savoir les investissements
un peu de tension avant le avant les
d'abord c'était notre aile droite veut
c'est ce qui participe de cette espèce
il ya quelques personnalités qui ont
d'accord bon ben merci messieurs je
veut accélérer et edouard philippe qui
pendant son discours d'accord lui d'être
faudrait vraiment qu'il est là amélie de
c'est ce que veut faire jean luc
rapprochement avec la france est soumise
le maire le 49-3 sur la réforme des
parce qu'il pense qu'il peut faire
et donc c'est un petit peu un chantier
fillon so nicolas sarkozy dans quelques
on avait une vingtaine de noms de la
libre elle parle énormément d'éducation
lasser ce mythe pardon c'est ce mythe du
l'accueil républicain et la mène
je sais que vous n'êtes pas psychologue
ensuite passage en revue de la garde
mélenchon c'est ce que faire marine le
résultats et puis surtout il ya la
que le premier premier ministre si j'ose
coup elle fait partie de la main grogne
dire que d'or philippe avec son parti
réussi à se faire connaître je pense à
de de brouillage permanent du
version résidentiel et qu'en réalité au
sur le chant basse à 9h30 et quand ils
ministres d'accord et donc ça c'est là
bouger les choses par exemple provoquant
au nom de son mouvement noël ça sent
crois qu'on a fait le tour on va suivre
dit oui mais si on accélère ça va poser
d'ailleurs voté pour lui en nous mêmes
cabinet de conseil forcément rien
pen je vois ce que me dit guillaume est
années aux états étrangères de films oui
lecture des résultats à opérer et
montchalin d'accord ministre de la
vous êtes journaliste mais est-ce que
républicaine canonnade depuis les
gouvernement resserré emmanuel macron la
alors ça ça n'a strictement aucune
sylvain maillard député de paris et
colonne ministre qu'on avait établi très
dire ce peut être quelqu'un qui a une
ça vous intéresse l'éducation
horizon il devait constituer un sas
nouveau un peu révolutionnaire si
une rencontre entre vladimir poutine et
c'est ce calcul c'est la semaine
ce temps l'imposant exactement la même
remaniement où tous les noms circulent
vous avez une idée de l'état d'esprit
mauvais non mais il ya d'autres il
retraites ça c'est une boulette par
rare sur lefigaro.fr me dis qu'on par
prendre un problème de droit pour
tout ça dans les dents les semaines à
rentrent du touquet à l'elysée pour
quelques autres comme ça mais c'est
sérieusement avec des pourcentages de
importance personne ne connaissait et
transformation public ministre la
jardins dj ça c'est en l'ancien régime
delà des idées qu'il a avancé des
emmanuel macron va au terme de ses
dans lequel emmanuel macron en ce moment
prochain exactement mais encore non pas
pas du tout je veux rester à bercy mais
volodymyr zelensky par exemple passer le
d'accueil pour les futurs excellent et
vocation présidentielle le lag alodia
d'ailleurs voté pour lui au second tour
j'entends simplifier et à ce moment là
dans tous les sens et puis à la fin tous
venir je rappelle vos bouquins arthur
d'incongru voilà pour vous faites le
expliquer expliquer il répond à une
yad'autres qui circule aussi à julien de
au don de me resservir moitié du
loire philippe quand il était nommé à
douleur la carte là alors il l'avait
fonction et de la transformation public
effectivement avec 7 ce fort score 58 %
propositions qu'il a faites pendant la
ambitions ça on pourra le dire que dans
poursuivre les résultats coup de fil de
devant 8 8 un exemple comme lui s'il n'y
difficile pour un personne qui vient du
où je comprends républicain emmanuel
ce c'est ce genre de choses pour
matignon personne ne connaissait jean
rapport à ce que vous vous expliquer
il est tendu il est inquiet des semaines
de vingt personnes y avaient pas edouard
interview on lui demande s'ils peuvent
sont déjà les ce serait un peu arrivé
lien chez vous avec la ferme à kingsey
normandie qui a huit ça ce sont les des
à se cristalliser se fixe un petit corps
se sont désormais beaucoup de cas sont
pourrait vampires ce rôle de
très courte campagne il va poursuivre
verbe à emmanuel macron vérité et
emmanuel macron se dit
cinq ans mais en tout cas un petit peu
sorti cette carte en 2017 en disant un
tout à l'heure d'edouard philippe au
philippe d'accord donc justement ça
castex c'est le pense le dernier la
la mairie de paris ça va pas être
naulleau mère c'était aussi un ancien
des étapes je ne suis axé le 21 ans
arrive pas ce qui est souvent dans ses
macron il s'est donc rendu par exemple à
quinquennat sarkozy mettait plusieurs
les frondeurs hertz allait finalement
on comprend bien ce que nous dit
monde de l'entreprise d'arrivée
utiliser le 49-3 pour faire passer parce
la la guerre de succession ça va très
qui arrivent où il ait confiance dans
porte-parole du gouvernement donc voyez
mensonge aider les gens les gens des
havre avec emmanuel macron il nous dit
après la bataille ans et josua et
propose simplement pour que les
conseiller de dominique de villepin pour
ce sont des propos rapportés un jeu et
révolutionnaire et donc ça ça pourrait
l'assemblée nationale dans un groupe
habitudes lorsqu'il s'agit de romagne
françois xavier dit moi les autres non
c'est un score de deuxième tour très
gouvernement resserré avec 15 et une
m'amène à ma dernière question de monkey
bon j'étais réélu avec mine de rien un
vite en politique on nous a dit déjà
choix en interne la normandie est-ce
il fait encore trop jour on pourra
poissy chez karl olive ou karl olive a
sur le thème majeur de son élection 2010
accélère qui seraient tentés par une
majoritaire et de devoir tout de suite
lui-même y est allé avant le début de la
années après c'était plusieurs c'est
légendes vérité la terre peut-être
et alors du côté gauche celui qui
que c'est un jeu de chaises musicales
qu'ils me disent qu'ils l'ont fait on
macron aime bien ou en tout cas prend
internautes comprennent bien puisque
intéresser oui jean castex il est loin
nous le maire les affaires étrangères ça
avec françois-xavier mois que le 24
vainqueur une vingtaine je me rappelle
ça rappelle ma cran et collante pendant
est ce vous savez on baisse les cases
légiférer bon la plupart n'ont pas
prime voilà ddd cabinet ministériel
élevé mais qui est quand même en recul
score solide c'est compliqué ce qu'il a
valoir au précise et juste des choses en
peut-être pas la lumière du ventre
sait-il des mensonges
pour ça que mickey lui dépose ses poses
dernière chose à laquelle emma qu'on
assez compliqué à arrêter définitivement
qu'il ne ressemble pas un peu trop
même macron se dit ce sont des malades
fait le show si je puis dire dans un
vous voulez qu'on leur donne une image
d'être le seul à être intéressé par
fonctionne aussi ça peut coller il fait
un déplacement ou président s'était
son temps souvent il ya une deuxième
février 2020 juste avant l'explosion du
plus ou moins un accord avec emmanuel
s'intéresse quand il nomme quelqu'un
pas du nombre exact donc ne vous
plutôt connus ou plutôt discret le
réussi et puis au gouvernement c'est la
d'accord peut-être même pas à 22h
elles se sont réduites ensuite avec jean
guerre guerre qui a démarré le 24
il a deux temporalités à gérer le temps
la transaction comme tout ce qu'ils
pour qu'il y en avait et les jambes
l'éducation nationale il ya un autre
langage trivial on se souvient de s'est
de 2 huit points par rapport à 2010 est
retourné à 10 et où emmanuel exactement
partie de ces lectures on sait par
avril au soir c'était la réélection des
quelqu'un à matignon vous les coraux
emmanuel macron c'est une sorte de
restreint d un spoil system à la
circule le plus alors donné ce grand la
voilà parce que
inquiétez pas si vous êtes parisien ce
bande qui est celle du 11 juillet donc
et c'est tout l'objet des discussions
même histoire jean michel blanquer au
d'ailleurs une farce penser que la tour
nouveau premier ministre dans le profil
marc ayrault qui après avoir quitté
février rendu quinze jours trois
macron pour pour essayer de sauver leur
avaient circulé vous souvenez on va être
rendu à pau chez françois bayrou qui lui
manuels maquereau et le début de la
exemple qu'il est proche de michel
c'est exactement ce qui s'est passé est
jour là pas de problème c'est la
copier-coller 1 dans le profil copie
le mercredi non pas huit mais comme on
gauche elisabeth bornes voilà elisabeth
précédent c'est pour ça que j'ai eu une
eiffel s'allume à 21h à 22h à 23h
confiné à telle date on va être
début il a été présenté comme la grande
voit que edouard philippe oppose à une
coc vide en france et le premier
semaines avant il s'est rendu à moscou
sont alors la cession précise quand même
pardon et puis françois-xavier bourmaud
matignon en 2014 et rappeler aux
guerre de succession d'accord et je vois
court il temps long le temps court c'est
houellebecq et on se dit beaucoup écrit
française pour que les administrations
fait des arbitrages
hésitation à l'état dit juppé y en avait
canonnade est une étape obligatoire et
d'ailleurs on sait je sais d'ailleurs je
aussi a rempli la salle de 500 personnes
déconstruit la tête d'adama très vite à
confinement edouard philippe fait passer
dit c'est en 15 peut-être elle a fait
bornes
des ménages macro on voit bien ce qu'il
prémonitoire macron le pen le tango des
réussite de la seule de la
travaille davantage et que l'exécutif et
conforme actuel ministre de
habituellement toute toutes les heures
tout de suite procédé à un remaniement
gouvernements valls toujours sous
à la joie damien par exemple de juin
puis à kiev il a rencontré vladimir
réponds à guillaume est rare que je
un autre en tête de premier ministre qui
c'est d'ailleurs et ça aussi c'est
dire qu'il suffit qu'une personne lance
bien l'idée est aussi un paramètre à
c'est pour ça que la prochaine fois
donc là il faudra avoir remanié donc
décision politique
essayait de faire dans son premier
ans les milieux restreints pour
pour faire la claque françois bayrou qui
en force à l'assemblée nationale le
que elizabeth ii serait la deuxième
salue en même temps
intéressant de le dire c'est la dernière
bruno le maire c'est typiquement le
toutes les heures donc colère de colère
c'est tout ça il en est revenu
transformation du passage de la société
françois hollande pour intégrer les
l'agriculture techno aussi très très
et le temps long s'est préparé son
fossoyeurs avec charles sapin vous
comme exactement damien abad qui a été
la technostructure
revenait au gouvernement c'est fabuleux
ça quelque part et puis ça ça fait tâche
parce qu'il ya deux rendez-vous aussi
qu'on viendra vous voir on aura sans
poutine puis volodymyr zelensky et donc
colle au président il s'est rendu à
prendre en compte qu'on voit pas encore
projet de réforme des retraites pas
aujourd'hui le gouvernement castex et 42
l'instant ministre ancien athlète atp et
femme premier ministre après des adieux
étape obligatoire puisque ensuite la
lorsque françois hollande dit ça c'est
civile à la vie politique et puis jean
affaires étrangères donc jusqu'à présent
qui était premier ministre de mitterrand
de d'emmanuel macron qui fait appeler
reçu et justement il a été reçu par qui
doute d'autres noms alors j'écoutais
quinquennat en tenant compte des
profil de l'homme politique de poids qui
parce qu'il n'a pas de majorité on pense
d'huile très rapidement c'est exactement
spézet dans le finistère le fief de
jean castex doit démissionner et puis il
administratives et là la rupture
il revient aux affaires étrangères avec
techno et si bien que son nom est plutôt
ils considèrent aujourd'hui que s'y
remontée des champs-elysées n'est pas
très bien là parce que les législatives
on a vu des anciens premiers ministres
revenez quand vous avez des infos
de cresson oui les autres possibilités à
qu'il ya beaucoup d'attenté en par la
membres 42 membres c'est l'un des
enseignements de l'élection or ces deux
michel blanquer r il en est un petit peu
par thierry solère non pas par et d'en
ancien socialiste ministre ex ps du
ce qui se passe pour un nom c'est à dire
rendre sans avoir la garantie la
rien ne
autour de lui finalement la tour eiffel
c'est danser dans six semaines mais le
pourrait aller à peu près partout voilà
richard ferrand je voulais aussi chers
messieurs merci beaucoup d'avoir été
obligatoire quand on est président
déjà la petite étape mais la parenthèse
commence à être consommés s'il a
records depuis les gouvernements
qui intégrait des postes régaliens
sépare disons que c'est le sait
que quelqu'un d'un peu proche du
revenu aujourd'hui il est un petit peu
temporalités elle s'imbrique pas
ya une cérémonie d'investiture qui doit
finir et donc en fait tous les salariés
gauche dites moi alors à gauche on va y
certitude si ce n'est d'obtenir quelque
vraiment la première brouille dont on a
france et dont il ya mort accélérée donc
travail elle a eu des réformes
réunion et ce qui n'est pas obligatoire
parents étaient toujours au dessus sur
n'accorde donc vous allez entendre tous
avec moi on va suivre ces postes de
scintille à 21h30 scintille à 22h
contesté en macro niant notamment depuis
raffarin et juppé d'autant que dans ces
premier ministre donc c'est celui qui
président lâche un nom le nom est
prestigieux et surtout des portes et des
était là pour le coup beaucoup plus long
aujourd'hui la situation gazeuse face à
forcément si bien que ça lui une lune
le conseiller de le continuer paulette
importantes à gérer durant le
et qu entre le entre les deux hommes et
chose au moins de faire bouger les
toutes les photos on le voit au dessus
non plus a rejoint le début de notre
là on parle de ce nouveau projet de
gère l'administration et c'est aussi le
avoir lieu quand même c'est obligatoire
et le bruno le maire c'est quasiment
aller
qu'il ya une vingtaine d'années et donc
quinquennat ancienne patronne de la ratp
répétée par quelqu'un qui le dit à
de l'épaule savez c'est le petit journal
ministres qui nous qui ont qu'on attend
42 membres très peu ont réussi à
problème c'est que lui entre temps il a
choses pour l'instant ce n'est pas à son
toutes ces histoires de déconfinement de
dans l'autre et ça suppose de trouver
pons est il au nautic d'emmanuel macron
trois anciens premiers ministres trois
entretien c'est que le discours à
puis ensuite ça va petit à petit se
réforme des retraites à bruno le maire
chef de la majorité c'est celui qui
quelqu'un qui dit à nouveau quelqu'un
affaires nationales puisqu'il sera aux
c'est un passage obligatoire même si le
des déséquilibres extrêmement complexe
j'ai placé à chaque point presse avec
elle était ministre des transports
laquelle on se trouve bien non il ya ces
ce que j'ai lu un mathieu klein parions
pour vous avez toujours pas de date à
fois revenu aux affaires et demandé à
venu de la droite député des
coup de téléphone du chancelier allemand
sax and systems dont françois en fait il
certain si ici s'il reste pas c'est que
l'hôtel de ville qui est une tradition
hier dans une interview sur une
agenda en revanche sur les premières
imprimer mal aidé par la crise duco vite
protocoles de protocoles kobe dans les
évalue que j'aimerais voir faire la
président reste le président la drôle de
affaires étrangères pendant leur mission
nous donner pour l'instant on va se
réforme de la sncf ouverture à la
des journalistes le président est là et
aussi rapidement ça n'est pas réapparu
hauts-de-seine excellèrent exactement
matinales radio et on lui demande s'il
lions là alors dites-moi qui m'intéresse
relevant le ou la maire de paris ne
qui voudraient ils viseraient
écoles etc et puis dans la société
même bernard cazeneuve alors cela ils
cérémonie oui parce qu'il doit à lille
mêmes macron l'a décidé de se passer
semaines de son alors que va-t-il faire
ça arrive ici sur ce plateau et nous on
labeaume dit voilà et qui pourra changer
retrouver soit avant le 11 mai parce que
ancien monsieur primaire de la droite en
bien sûr mais en tout cas il est revenu
l'éducation nationale là on est dans le
puis yahia la personnalité derrière
voilà et il fait son discours autres
concurrence fin du statut des cheminots
pourrait à nouveau avoir recours aux 49
euros c'est énorme ce qu'il ya une
parce que c'est un poids lourd quid de
l'est pas obligatoire non plus si tu
sachant qu'en plus il ya le deuxième
doit se voir remettre les pouvoirs
civile il y avait de grands espoirs et
donne les noms donnez moi des des pistes
gabriel talent peut nous donner des
2016 il faut le rappeler est donc
sont leurs noms reviennent pour intégrer
d'un atout dans son jeu en tout cas il
edouard philippe emmanuel macron décide
et et compagnie ensuite il y avait deux
9h40 et 9h50 et pas deux pas des tours
que peut-il proposer pour bien entrer
clan gens dans le national et
devais parler de ceux de ses relations
si la major et si ça se passe mal dans
3 en cas de difficulté et dire que je ne
petite pause du témoin ne l'a en
infos demain à la sortie du conseil des
militaires donc il ya une chronique
de ce mythe du gouvernement resserré et
j'en terminerai par là puisque je vois
edouard philippe n'a pas accompli sa
l'international et jean castex pour
gérald darmanin qu'est-ce qu'on en fait
qu'ils actifs sans faire de belles
un peu tendues avec est tout à fait et
de se rendre au havre dans l'entre-deux
parlerait d'un d'une reconduction
ministres la question qui sera posée on
en tout cas ce qui est dont on peut
la majorité si emmanuel macron n'obtient
peux pas l'exclure et donc c'est ça la
votre jeu vraiment
va falloir lui trouver autre chose c'est
extrêmement protocolaire ou il sera
et fait une ligne autour de saintes et
bornes elle était ministre de l'écologie
si j'allais revenir il ya 2 de deux
justement la guerre en ukraine fait le
tours hélas edouard philippe il a il a
moi juste autre chose sur les les
m'est avis qu'ils emmanuel macron ne
mission d'être un sas les christian
revenir à votre exactement pour revenir
immédiate c'est en effet ce n est jamais
suivra ça et puis je renvoie quand même
arthur frais qu'elle avait déjà bloqué
sympa eric dupond-moretti avoir des nord
voulais tu sais c'est la boulette parce
présumer pour l'instant présent dans le
la célèbre formule je préfère avoir
aura importants expliqué pourquoi arthur
lien c'est à dire que il a été privé
là imagine jean castex président et
pas une majorité à sa main s'il faut
à votre question initiale d'abord oui il
choisira pas de retenir cette option
le choix entre deux attitudes il est
à cet article des du candidat au
estrosi les hubert falco les renaud
emmanuel macron ya cinq ans les
que ça rentre en contradiction totale
d'une campagne à cause de la guerre en
a imprimé auprès des français c'est à
plus intéressant dans ce dites moi dans
soit discret soit fuyant mais jamais
cette année on imagine qu'ils l'appuient
c'est comme ça on y présidait le conseil
relations entre emmanuel macron et
muselier toute cette droite de paca elle
quelqu'un qui est dans l'attenté qui
avec la nouvelle méthode promise par mm
parce que hull où la future prochain
bâtir une coalition enfin tout ça et
président les secrets de macron deux
ukraine c'est à dire qu'il n'a pas pu
du barreau et qu'il lui fasse une
présents d'accord c'est à dire qu à
des ministres en tant que premier
dire que moi j'ai eu la gelée suivi
fait bon emmanuel macron toujours encore
l'hidalgo sont très mauvaises elles
faire campagne aussitôt que ce qu'il
pisse dehors plutôt que des pistes dans
chaque fois qu emmanuel macron fait à ce
et elle a rejoint le giron macro nist
puis même s'il a la majorité il faudra
ministre passe d'ailleurs sa présidente
sets aujourd'hui dans le figaro il ya
l'ont toujours été mais aller à 5 ans
transition parfaite devait être le
prochaine premier ministre sera
qu'on appelle un bain de foule une
macro de dialogue et d'écouté donc la
aurait souhaité ou en tout cas c'est ce
et toujours maître des horloges vous
qui préside à éliminer il le coco
la tente j'aime aussi
plein d'infos voilà la politique
déambulation il salue les gens et dans
bernard tapie d' emmanuel macron celui
mais pas grâce à edouard philippe donc
emmanuel macron pour sa prime aux
trouver quelqu'un qui soit au point d'
directement charge de la planification
qui te dit pas pu se rendre suffisamment
continue sur sur figaro live demain à
renvoie à l'excellent papier de franck
équilibre des différentes composantes de
élections voulait fêter son élection sur
ça c'est la première partie de la phrase
filippi les dimanches je les ai suivis
qu'ils aient ferraillé avec le le fn
écologistes écologique c'était la grande
n'hésitez pas à vous poser si vous avez
sur le terrain à cause de cette guerre
vincent rosereau fera lui un point
boulette elle est importante elle est au
tout particulièrement il arrivé glisser
c'était notre aile droite c'est devenu
lavier d'arthur de ce matin il ya toutes
la majorité donc tout ça laisse encore
le changement d g real a fait cette
en ukraine et donc il veut rattraper le
annonce des matches ce sera marié min
tout début donc elle va peut-être pas un
complet sur ce qui se passe chez les
des expressions comme ça vous ne les
un aileron c'est la deuxième moitié de
ville est déjà sur le champ de mars et
planer le flou alors vous vouliez des
temps perdu rattraper le temps perdu
républicains réunis aujourd'hui en
données sur le chat vous posez des
la phrase c'est devenu un aileron c'est
noms alors attendez attendez je j'y
fusée on peut supposer que la france est
puis à l'époque la mairie de paris
c'est quoi c'est multiplier les
questions vous nous avancer des noms et
conseil stratégique c'est la crise chez
à double sens et c'est très violent un
toujours mais par la merde donc anne
soumise par les oppositions vont tout
déplacements et donc il a apprécié le
on essaie de voir si ça colle avec les
les républicains et puis point de vue ce
aileron d'abord c'est plus petit qu'une
soir arbon alban barthélémy aux
faire pour attiser ça mais le nouveau
différents ministères arthur d'autres
formate série déplacement ce gaz est
elle est ensuite un aileron on pense
commandes discutera de cette grande
noms d'autres membres l'ornement qui
tous à la j'ose le requin donc un
[Musique]